[Music]
have you guys been like the rest of the
world and being antibacterial wipe crazy
nope no you don't have to use that home
all the time true I got eczema
masturbates my problem hands you don't
wipe off your hands but isn't it one of
the most sterile things come as super
sterile right guys for like STDs yeah
well if it's your own you can't infect
yourself why still trying to keep my
calm six feet away from people Oh
minimum twenty seconds I learned about
wash my hands like a chef now I like
doing I never done this motion before I
never did this thing have you guys went
through a whole journey of understanding
how soap works and why soap is better
than antibacterial and where soap came
from and all the studies and [ __ ] yeah I
just know that your soap washes it off
antibacterial just kill some know that
kills it huh so wheels up
twenty-second bean kills it ball so
Washington yeah that type of kill it's
still ahead yeah yeah with I think I am
forgetting all this guy learn all this
[ __ ] with when I went to school and
stuff but the hospital and so now
everyone's talking about PPE and like
and time disinfectant sanitizing like
the difference between all this stuff
and I'm like oh it's reminding me of my
old life but yeah like with
antibacterial why the gel stuff it it
there's a quicker time for germs to get
on your hands versus if you wash them
with water and so yeah and then the
problem with the anti bacterial a lot of
times too that not all of them meet the
minimum requirements of how much alcohol
is in there yes a lot of its you're not
even doing anything you have to be like
over 60% compared to no matter what soap
you have they all work equally yeah even
the [ __ ] bar soap from the hotel yes its
antibacterial my antivirus
exactly yeah no it's that's they both
work the same it's just alcohol this
list here is
things are you doing wrong with
antibacterial wipes you can also get
someone to lick your hand for you yeah
and if they get the wrong I like get
away from me you just stick your hand
out like this
and then you get a bunch of puppies to
lick your hands because you know how the
dogs they have other suppose out but
yeah even that word trigger word from my
past life what puppies cuz I used to I
used to work no I used to work um in
sanitizing Surgical Instrument so I used
to disinfect and sanitize and do all
that [ __ ] so all of this was my field so
anyway so the first mistake is not
reading the labels so you have to make
sure that you are using the label
property like the the actual answer
material wipe properly because a lot of
these wipes like let me get that
klauridsen part this one kills 99.99% of
bacteria kills cook it blue viruses it
kills flu viruses yeah one of them says
the word trigger work Koby yeah wait
this one says kill staff Ecola mrs a
Salmonella and strep throat yeah they
might be close yeah I think this one why
is this all in Spanish
oh yeah we're here it says uh like the
stuff of Coco Coco and then the human
the bad word that we can't say because
then we're gonna get to monitize what's
in there yeah
it says here human alona virus influenza
A - you have to read the labels and also
it also tells you how long you're
supposed to leave it wet so for example
here for this one in particular says it
must remain visibly wet for four minutes
whoa damn I tried right off right away
no so it says like to sit two more
minutes
so it says used to disinfect hard
non-porous surfaces wipe surface with
white fur surface to be disinfected use
enough wipes for treated surface to
remain visibly wet for four minutes
let surface dry I want to see something
visitability wear for four minutes and
it has to do with the other gender
Horvitz is this front amount of time you
think so wet [ __ ] for four minutes
another UAV
yeah okay that is like staring at like
titties at a strip club for four minutes
you don't know how thirsty I am the
first 30 seconds though yeah without
doing anything I don't think I could
resist really would you do dance - can
you imagine if someone's looking at your
[ __ ] and you're doing this [ __ ] it's
not like money are you yeah I'm just
here for the music another thing you're
doing wrong with using disinfecting
wipes is you are not cleaning the syrup
like visibly dirty surfaces like for
example if you like spill some sauce in
your kitchen or whatever you're trying
to clean it with a disinfecting white
you have to first clean the sauce with
the regular paper towel and then use the
distance yeah you can't just mix the two
yeah good cuz you're not killing
anything like you're just spreading it
you're not reading more ketchup on the
[ __ ] table yeah I've been doing it
wrong what yeah I just I take the clean
wipe my battle it out guys
oh man what's a dry dry basket is just
cleaning it up and no more bloodshed
guys hey yeah I usually get the dry one
first I wipe it use the wet one proper
way to do I get scared to use chemicals
oh that's another thing so they're
saying it let me find it it's okay so
for the chemical thing is another wrong
thing you're doing which this one I
didn't know is using it on your phone
screen you're not supposed to use this
on your phone phone all the time don't
so it says antibacterial wipes shouldn't
be used on everything while cleaning
your electronics is certainly important
using antibacterial wipes on it could
actually be damaging because they should
they should be used on the back or the
like button on glass parts of your
phones only because the chemicals in the
wipes can break down the coating on
screens as opposed to prevent things
that's why you have glass protectors
[ __ ] up my macbook real bad so you can
use Windex on the glass part no yeah
that one thing I see people at the
grocery start with gloves but they're so
using their phone and put into their
face and I'm like okay that's not
working
yeah another thing about the chemical
stuff is using it for kids toys and pet
bowls this is not meant to be ingested
so you know kids put their toys in the
mouth you're not supposed to use these
harsh chemicals on things like that it's
I I think it's okay if you use it to
disinfect it then go back and wipe it
with yo don't give it to them doing that
for a minute we know while it's still
wet if I put this in your mouth now oh
so they don't like chemicals yeah they
said that use water-based non chemical
solution to it like bleach or soap no
what about just good old-fashioned
[ __ ] vinegar or like baking sodas
well that's like a like a basically like
a disinfectant I use will partly vinegar
like five parts water and then you use
that instead of a while and now
everything smells like vinegar no it
evaporates I got a lot of lemons you
guys think that'll work oh the lemons
work I've been use that for my grills or
vinegar for
rid of the gunk on my pants after I like
pan-fried [ __ ] I'm like stuck and yeah I
don't want to spend forever
scrubbing it with soap so then I just
pour vinegar or some lemon juice and you
heat it up and then just comes right off
so actually that's crazy can awesome
yeah I didn't know that and so I just
did it and I was like partisan that gunk
is flavor left on that it is if you have
a skillet it kind of supposed to wash it
true true skillets
cast iron right cast iron her [ __ ] so
old girl are we talking about cleaning
techniques I ruined my pot because I was
busy and I was making like oxtail soup
and that shouldn't burn like a
[ __ ] right I didn't know what to
do and then I did a solution of baking
soda and vinegar and that like it was a
chemistry project like a volcano but I
still didn't do anything then explode
and then I got coffee grinds used coffee
grinds from my [ __ ] and I was like let
me see if this works
throw that [ __ ] in there
scrubbed it with a metal wire thing yeah
BAM dude it worked what was the one when
you're as cool you did the penny or you
clean the penny was that like vinegar
and like I think it was or something
like that but whatever that is I need to
start using that true okay another thing
you're doing wrong is you're using one
wipe to clean more than one thing you're
spreading germs from one thing - this is
a conspiracy from [ __ ] Clorox that's
trying to get you to use more I know
what you're trying to do a [ __ ] think
about it like you imagine you use the
same wipe to clean the toilet handle and
then you go to your doorknob
we go door knob then toilet handle true
I've seen the less nerdy thing first
yeah should be do be I should clean idea
one wipe and I cleaned the other wipe
[Laughter]
another thing is flushing it down the
toilet so they're saying in this clog in
the car so they're saying don't even you
don't even flush down wipes that say
flushable in the packaging either
because the chemicals and [ __ ] well not
just that but wife started thicker
yeah they don't break down as easy
there's a big thing that started coming
out with a year ago that people are like
stop using flushable wipes because
normally normal toilet is this a flush
yeah well no toilet paper breaks down as
soon as it touches water right yeah but
then like this one is sits in water all
the time in the packaging so obviously
it doesn't break down if we can break
down our [ __ ] can't break down a Clorox
wipe a flushable one maybe yeah well
just forget you the plant oh yeah yeah
have you seen those pictures where they
pull out the giant like the de Blasio
wads of flushable wipes and [ __ ] from
the sewers it's crazy
oh don't fuss about it don't if you if
you own the house if you read you - yeah
I'm not gonna totally new headspace now
that I know nice shower actually cause
like a lot of hair comes up I actually
leave it on the side and Mike I collect
it all until and then I dude having a
beard
I'm like why the [ __ ] is my toilet
flooding or by my bathroom my tub flood
flooding that didn't stop it or pull
like something but just all fear you dig
battle Oh like in the shower yeah like
when you when you grab that ball of hair
from the pipe in it's like you mean it
catches all the gunk in it - yeah
gunk yeah yay are the gunk in the sorry
yeah yeah stay clean and safe out there
people yeah and then the last few is
don't use it on wood and make sure you
don't use it after it's expired cousin
is pointless don't use it on anything
god this is soap use some soap on your
hands use itself on your tables put soap
on everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]